alors un petit peu parce que c'est la
première fois vous êtes à côté de moi
marc-antoine le bret vous allez regarder
bien sûr à 17h20 valérie damidot à
samedi oui merci bras mais cela il veut
pas il veut pas donner sa vraie voix en
fait marc antoine donc dès qu'on lui
pose une question en lui même il dit oui
vous me ferez marc-antoine le bret qui
nous donne des nouvelles des stars du
paf et des stars aussi du cinéma il ya
quelqu'un dont on a envie d'avoir des
nouvelles chaque semaine un ca c'est un
beau gosse faire des beaux gosses du
cinéma français c'est dans son cas c'est
trop oui j'aimerais chanter c'est là
qu'est ce qu'il ya là haut
qu'est ce qu'il ya ça va ça non je vais
juste donner un conseil déco valérie
damidot mais bon valérie si la maison tu
déconnes tu veux qu'elle soit vraiment
magnifique il ya un truc à faire
tu m'invites dans ton émission c'est
pourquoi est ce que je suis dans un
endroit et ben il devient magnifique
oui oui oui je me kiffe web où là aussi
des nouvelles de jean luc lemoine hewitt
mon cher sert il
alors comme on peut le voir sur ce
plateau la vie est mal faite
en effet comment expliquer que sur la
tête de valérie bénaïm chaque cheveu est
parfaitement à sa place ici alors qu'au
même moment sur la tête de christophe
carrière pas un seul cheveu est à sa
place je n'ai pas de suite à cette
blague juste une chute de cheveux un bon
jeu de mots comme ça je sens que thierry
moreau nano l'envié lui qui revient tout
le temps je vois là on met des images de
lui chaque semaine on aime bien
quotidien de voir c'est julien lepers oh
c'est pour dida donc je suis plus long
que la muraille de chine je n'ai pas de
chute et je suis raconter avec la voix
de maïté je suis je suis
une anecdote d'isabelle morini bas
on reste concentré
cette deuxième question l'arrivée du
jour les jours jusqu'au départ grâce et
le languedoc comme vous faites à chaque
fois les longues bottes l'élite embarras
et je salue également les retraités qui
nous regardent ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux coucou gérard louvin alors
aulas qu'est-ce qui se passe tu gagnes
l'encyclopédie de la meilleure anecdote
d'isabelle on 750 volume alors on en
parlait tout à l'heure ça va les frères
bogdanov ou pas bonjour mon cher cyril
laissez moi vous raconter une histoire
j'ai pensé l'autre jour parce que
j'étais tranquillement assis sur mon
temps quand cela je me suis fait tension
et gore non je me suis fais attention
grichka parce que je suis grichka non je
dis gars je ne sais plus comme nous
sommes jumeaux je ne confonds tout le
temps bref je dois vous laisser
il faut que j'aille me raser j'en ai
quand même pour cinq heures
bernard de la villardière il en france
en ce moment pas bonsoir c'est bernard
de la villardière la mèche au vent et la
braguette ouverte
sachez que je suis sur ce plateau pour
annoncer la prochaine émission intitulée
télévision sexe et luxure 24 heures dans
la vie de jean michel bayle un reportage
à découvrir dans le prochain numéro
donc et kate excusez nous refaire le
bonjour de bernard laville à dire quand
vous vous retournez pas ce que je sais
c'est beau ce book pourquoi enfin on a
des nouvelles du plus grand dj de france
david guetta c'est bien ça
je suis le seul mec
vous avez vu la semaine dernière les cas
si on a divorcé
c'est horrible ouais
franchement c'est super triste c'est pas
grave parce que pour mettre l'alliance
j'ai besoin que d'un seul doigt quand je
me remarierai jaune pour faire un de mes
disques